[موسيقى]
بالعاده يعني على اكثر من مستوى المستوى
الاول داخل السجن الواحد نفسه يعني هي
المهاجع متلاصقه يعني بين المهجر والمهجى
هناك حائط مشترك على الاغلب
كان يتم التواصل عبر النقر على الحيطه
يعني
كان من زمان يعني
صارت قديمه فكان في بعض الناس
يعني يعرفون ابجديه مورس
جديد مرسل
فيها الارسال البرقيات يعني نعم نقرا شحطه
نقرا نقرا شحطه يعني فكان عبر الحائط
واللي كان بيعرف ابجديه مورس بيعلمها
لباقي السجناء كل طريقه لها معنى كل نقره
كل يعني كل حرف له اشارات معينه يعني
فكانوا عبر الحائط طبعا يتبادلوا
المعلومات البسيطه يعني مثل مثلا كم واحد
انتم بالمهجاع جاكم حدا جديد بتعرفوا شيء
عن اخبار الخارج في شيء كذا لسه في
اشتباكات مثلا طبعا كحركه دينيه يعني كانت
فاتو كان في اشتباكات بين
الطليعه المقاتله والنظام والسلطه يعني
وانه لا زال في اشتباكات ولا بطلوا في شيء
يعني اكتر شي بنسال عنه يعني في شيء
اشاعات بره بانه بده يصير في عفو مثلا
هاي المسائل تبادلها عبر الحائط طبعا
بالمهاجئ اللي متوفر فيها شخص يجيد اب
جديد مورس وشرط يكون المهجع الملاصق له
ينوجد ايضا شخص اخر يجيد اب جديد